dc's cinematic history spans over half a
century
and in that time they've released some
of the most memorable comic book movies
ever made from batman's beginnings to
zack snyder's justice league
these are the most iconic scenes from
every live-action dc movie
1966's batman contains a scene that
perfectly encapsulates the campy tone of
60zera batman
upon discovering a smoking bomb in the
united underworld's hq
batman dashes out of the building to
dispose of it unfortunately
he runs into well basically everything
from a mother with a baby to a gaggle of
nuns to a full brass band
cue batman's now legendary lament
some days you just can't get rid of a
bomb luckily the ever resourceful caped
crusader eventually manages to dispose
of the bomb
while ducking beside some lead pipes to
shield himself from the blast
utterly ridiculous and totally hilarious
this scene is adam west's batman at its
absolute best considered to be a classic
film in its own right 1978 superman was
one of the first dc films to actually
take its hero seriously
and part of that means following a young
clark kent's life in smallville as such
by the end of the movie's first
act most audiences will be eager to see
superman make his proper debut
luckily they won't be disappointed
either although the man of steel first
appears in the fortress of solitude he
truly reveals himself to the world after
a disastrous helicopter takeoff
threatens the life of lois lane seeing
he's needed
clark kent races across the street rips
open his shirt and reveals the famous
s emblem on his chest after spinning
through a revolving door superman takes
to the sky and catches lois midfault
accompanied by john williams's classic
superman score
this iconic moment set the standard for
all future superman movies
superman 2 sees clark kent sacrifice his
powers to be with lois lane
unfortunately his decision coincides
with the reappearance of a trio of
kryptonian criminals led by the
nefarious general zod
realizing that only superman can stop
this threat clark manages to re-energize
his powers at the fortress of solitude
back in metropolis zod and his cronies
invade the daily planet and threaten to
kill
everyone in the building unless the son
of jor-el
appears just as all hope seems lost the
wind blows the music swells
and a familiar caped figure soars into
the room
general would you care to step outside
superman is famous for his dramatic
entrances and
last second arrivals and this moment is
the best of the very
best the first swamp thing movie was
released when comic book films were
still trying to strike a balance between
serious storytelling and campy comedy as
such the main character comes across
as kind of a b-movie monster albeit a
more heroic one
it only seems natural then that the
scene in which swamp thing fights his
arch enemy arcane
is legendarily cheesy both characters
are obviously wearing rubber suits and
the bestial arcane for some reason
decides to use a sword against his
opponent
this is comic book cinema at its
absolute
goofiest not that there's anything wrong
with that
despite its reputation as one of the
weaker entries in the superman movie
franchise superman 3 contains one of the
most iconic scenes in superman movie
history
the eerie sequence in which clark kent
battles superman
after gus gorman creates a synthetic
form of kryptonite he exposes superman
to the toxic substance which eventually
splits the hero into two beings
a good clark kent and an evil superman
the two then come to blows in a junkyard
where superman tries to destroy the
nerdy alter ego once and for all
clark refuses to succumb however and
finally strangles his corrupt
counterpart
causing the evil superman to vanish into
thin air in the aftermath
clark rips open his shirt showing off
his bright s
shield and soars away as superman reborn
it's a magnificent sequence in let's
face it a less than magnificent movie
though it ultimately failed to expand
the superman movie franchise supergirl
still
offers a memorable performance by helen
slater as cara zorel
and arguably her finest moment takes
place when she first arrives on earth
where she discovers
both the wonders of the natural world
and her new superpowers
cara picks up a rock and accidentally
crushes it in her hand
she plucks a flower make it blooms with
her heat vision and is shocked and
delighted when she finds herself
floating as she grows more comfortable
somersaulting through the air supergirl
takes her first proper flight
soaring through the clouds and finally
settling down to watch the sunset
this is a genuinely beautiful scene
unlike any you'll find in the other
superman movies
it's just a shame the rest of the movie
doesn't measure up
although it's generally regarded as the
worst superman movie one sequence in
superman 4 stands out
the battle between superman and his
solar powered clone nuclear man
created by lex luthor to destroy the man
of steel nuclear man decides to first
have fun by flying around the world and
causing a number of disasters
naturally superman follows nuclear men
and manages to set
everything right although budget
constraints and some weak storytelling
leads him to develop some strange new
powers in the process
still despite the poor special effects
it's actually a lot of fun seeing
nuclear men wreak havoc on famous world
landmarks
by 1989 swamp thing had undergone a
revival in dc comics thanks to superstar
writer alan moore's reconfiguration of
the character
the return of swamp thing largely
ignored these changes however opting
instead to lean into the comic b-movie
side of things
dick durrock reprises his role as swamp
thing but displays a more casual
attitude as he takes the fight to
several new monsters
one particularly funny scene unfolds
when a baseball bat wielding swamp thing
saves a couple kids from some bad guys
when the kids try to take a photo of him
for the tabloids swam thing not only
obliges he has one of the kids posed
with him in the shot
if only bigfoot was this accommodating
tim burton's 1989 film batman set a new
tone for live-action depictions of the
dark knight
no longer the campy crime fighter of the
1960s tv show batman could now be
portrayed as the brooding
serious hero he was in the comic books
and nowhere is this made
more clear than with his first
appearance in which he steps out of the
shadows to take down
two muggers what are you
i'm batman with these two simple words
keaton set a whole new precedent for the
character of batman
unsurprisingly this iconic line has been
repeated in practically
every batman film and tv series since as
it so
effectively communicates everything you
need to know about the dark knight
i am batman i'm batman
i'm batman hey i'm batman i'm
batman i'm batman i'm batman
and we all know exactly what that means
because keaton made it
perfectly clear the first time around
one thing that's certain about tim
burton's batman movies is that the
villains almost always
overshadow the hero take catwoman for
example michelle pfeiffer's selena kyle
goes through a dramatic character arc in
the film starting out as a humble
secretary to her corrupt boss
max shrek after he pushes her out of a
window selena is revived by a colony of
cats and
transforms into a more aggressive
version of herself
her first big action scene establishes
exactly who this catwoman is
when she sees a mugger assault a young
woman catwoman brutally kicks the thug
in submission
clawing his face into a bloody pulp for
good measure and then she does something
even
more surprising she assaults the
would-be victim too
you make it so easy don't you always
waiting for some bad man to save you
that's selena kyle all right
say what you will about the joel
schumacher batman films but they at
least have a distinctive style
all their own batman forever sets the
tone right away in its opening scene in
which bruce wayne dons his bat suit and
chooses his weapons
this scene is so instantly memorable
that it's even parodied within
the same movie when bruce dons a new
prototype suit and gives the audience a
close-up of his now
infamous bat butt the sequence is also
repeated in the sequel batman and robin
and is now considered one of the dark
knight's most infamous and
embarrassing moments batman and robin is
a movie that seems
dead set on one upping itself with
increasingly bizarre and ridiculous
moments
one scene however elevates the silliness
to almost unbelievable levels
while appearing at a charity benefit
auction batman and robin are exposed to
pheromone laden love dust courtesy of
poison ivy they then proceed to bid
against each other for the right to date
the villainous and then
this happens seven million
never leave the cave without it although
the bat credit card is one of the most
heavily ridiculed gadgets in the caped
crusaders long history it is at least a
fun callback to the endearing absurdity
of the 60s version of batman
and if nothing else it also emphasizes
bruce wayne's one true superpower
his money in the comics steel is john
henry irons
a weapons designer who builds an armored
suit to honor superman
after the man of steel dies fighting
doomsday the movie version however
simply has john henry and his partner
susan sparks build the suit to take down
weapons dealer
in the film's climax berks thugs
captures sparks
but as she quickly shows she's installed
a few surprises in her chair
while the film was rightly panned on its
release this scene
is at least surprisingly memorable for
its sheer ridiculousness alone
the 2004 catwoman movie has been widely
criticized for its nonsensical plot
bad acting and poor special effects
given that the film was nominated for
seven golden raspberry awards it won't
surprise you to learn that the movie's
most iconic scene
isn't exactly a great one the scene in
question is the infamous basketball
scrimmage between patients and her love
interest detective tom lone
after being challenged to a one-on-one
basketball game by some kids
patience uses her cat-like coordination
and agility to flirt with lone
eventually dunking the ball from the
free throw line it's a silly unnecessary
and horribly edited scene that is
thoroughly ridiculed to this day
much like the movie itself keanu reeves
may have seemed like a strange choice to
play dc's
chain smoking magic wielding anti-hero
constantine at the time but the film has
since gone on to gain something of a
cult following
one of the movie's best scenes comes
when constantine attempts to find a
detective's twin sister by going to hell
and looking for her there
in the process he braves an army of
demons to snatch her hospital wristband
hoping to at least return it to her
sister that image of constantine
reaching upward for the wristband as
devil's attempt to drag him down to hell
perfectly symbolizes the character's
struggles with his own demons
it's not exactly subtle but this is a
great sequence in a surprisingly good
movie
batman begins was arguably the first
batman film that was truly about
batman offering an in-depth look at the
childhood trauma that shapes bruce wayne
the movie spends much of its run time
showing bruce training and growing
before he finally reveals himself as
batman and it's one of these moments
that stands out as its most iconic scene
at the start of the film a young bruce
wayne develops a phobia of bats after
falling into a cave near wayne manor
later having lost his parents and
mastered his fears under the guidance of
razal ghul
bruce returns to the cave and is once
again attacked by bats
this time however bruce remains calm and
lets the bats circle him
immersing himself in his worst fear he
might not be wearing the suit yet but in
that moment
bruce wayne truly becomes batman
brian singer's superman returns was
intended to be a continuation of
christopher reeve's superman films but
was criticized for its somber depiction
of the man of steel
and the unnecessary introduction of
superman's son
jason nevertheless superman returns is
filled with plenty of visually stunning
sequences
in which superman shows off his godlike
abilities one particularly memorable
scene occurs shortly after superman's
return when he floats above the earth
and uses his super hearing to listen to
all the voices on the planet
as soon as he hears a single cry for
help he leaps into action and plummets
back down to earth
whatever his flaws may be superman is
supposed to be earth's greatest
protector
and this scene demonstrates that in full
heath ledger's magnetic performance as
the joker in the dark knight earned him
a well-deserved posthumous oscar
and while virtually all of ledger scenes
could be considered iconic in their
own right the interrogation scene
between batman and the joker is probably
the best of all
in this scene the joker takes the
opportunity offered by his face to face
with batman
to deliver some of the best lines in
comic book movie history
see i'm not a monster
i'm just ahead of the curve this is a
truly gripping scene
made even more disturbing by the fact
that the joker makes
no effort to defend himself when things
get violent yet still manages to get
everything he wants as far as depictions
of the joker go
it really doesn't get much better than
this
while there are a few slight differences
between zack snyder's watchmen
adaptation and the comic on which it's
based one iconic scene is especially
faithful to the original work
the birth of dr manhattan being the only
character in the story with
actual superpowers dr manhattan's
creation is suitably dramatic
after being accidentally locked in a
test chamber scientist john ostermann is
literally
torn apart by an experimental generator
and left as a powerful disembodied
consciousness
over the next few months john learns to
rebuild himself
finally reappearing as an omnipotent
blue superman
narrated to perfection by billy crudup
the entire sequence is both haunting
and riveting years before he made
history as thanos in the mcu
josh brolin portrayed one of dc's more
obscure anti-heroes
the bounty hunter jonah hex while the
2010 jonah hex film alters the character
somewhat by giving him the mystical
power of resurrecting the dead it does
at least retain hex's most distinctive
feature
his heavily scarred face in the movie
hex is disfigured after his confederate
commanding officer quinton turnbull
brands hex's face with his initials
hex then removes the brand by
intentionally scarring that half of his
face
later a smart mouthed thug asks what
happened to his face while brandishing a
knife hex guns him down
then simply quips cut myself shaving
what happened to yours green lantern is
a movie so thoroughly mocked that even
its star ryan reynolds has taken a
well-deserved shot at it
you're welcome canada despite the film's
problems however there is one standout
scene in which hal recites the green
lantern oath
and is propelled through a wormhole to
owa the home planet of the green lantern
corps
hal flies over a vast sprawl of
futuristic buildings past
the central power battery and into an
assembly of lanterns who reveal that
he's now part of something much bigger
than himself
the dark knight rises offers one iconic
scene that's actually deceptively
low-key for a batman movie
in the film's final scenes bruce's
butler alfred pennyworth takes a holiday
to italy and spies bruce sitting at a
nearby table with selena kyle having
finally let go of his vigilante
lifestyle
alfred then leaves happy that bruce has
found happiness outside of gotham city
unlike other batman films which suggests
that the dark knight is eternally locked
into his crusade
christopher nolan's dark knight trilogy
offers something new closure
here and nowhere else bruce wayne is
finally able to enjoy the happy ending
he deserves
zack snyder's man of steel is full of
controversial choices
from the movie's grim tone to superman's
decision to kill
general zod at the story's climax this
film continues to divide fans to this
day
one scene however truly embraces the joy
of being superman
upon discovering a kryptonian scout ship
in the arctic clark kent
dons his kryptonian suit and steps into
the sun ready to learn how to fly
gradually clark progresses from super
leaps to actual flight
soaring through clouds and canyons
before finally reaching orbit
the look on superman's face as he
realizes what he can be is genuinely
heartwarming and
demonstrates the true potential of
superman at his best
batman vs superman attracted all kinds
of criticism when it was released in
2016 but one thing the movie did get
right was the titular showdown between
the man of steel and the dark knight
tell me
do you plead this sequence sees an older
deadlier bruce wayne employ
everything from sonic cannons to
kryptonite gas to gain the edge on his
god-like opponent
and it works too although the two
eventually stop fighting to team up
batman definitely gets in a good few
hits against superman and
at one point almost takes him down for
good it's a potent reminder of just how
powerful
a well-prepared batman can be while
suicide squad received countless dire
reviews from the critics
many of them at least praised both the
action and margot robbie's performance
as harley quinn however
it's another character will smith's
deadshot who stars in the movie's most
iconic scene
when his team ends up fighting an army
of demonic monsters the master assassin
deadshot manages to convince the
villains to fight alongside the military
to survive
then just as the demons threaten to
overwhelm them deadshot
steps up he uses his uncanny aim and an
arsenal of weaponry to take out
every single demon even as they get
close enough to tear him apart
by the end of the film deadshot is still
anything but a hero
but he has still managed to earn the
respect of even his hard-nosed military
handler
wonder woman's best scene perfectly
communicates exactly who wonder woman
is and where her strengths lie as a hero
after accompanying steve trevor to
europe to help fight world war
1 diana finds herself on the front lines
in belgium
here steve claims that moving through
the battlefield is more or less
impossible as the men have been fighting
for months and barely gained an inch of
ground in that time
in response diana removes her cloak
climbs the parapet and begins to walk
across
no man's land a barrage of bullets and
bombs try to bring her down but the
amazonian princess refuses to give up
eventually leading the allied forces to
victory it's a stunningly shot action
sequence
that really shows wonder woman for the
inspirational symbol of strength that
she is
the theatrical release of justice league
greatly altered zack snyder's original
vision
as such it's also deeply unpopular among
the fans who successfully lobbied for
the release of zack snyder's justice
league in march 2021.
one scene however did excite many fans
back in 2017
after being resurrected by an alien
mother box superman emerges from his
tomb in an amnesiac state
and almost immediately attacks the newly
formed justice league
their combined might isn't nearly enough
to restrain him
of course and he even proves himself
fast enough to keep
up with the flash himself obviously
superman later returns as the justice
league's ally but this scene did a
pretty great job in showing why you
don't mess with the last son of krypton
fully embracing the fantastical aspects
of the character
aquaman immerses its hero in an atlantis
bursting with color and life
there he accepts a quest to recover a
powerful trident that will grant him
control over all
sea life what this really means is made
clear in the movie's climactic battle
scene in which aquaman shows up to an
all-out war
between opposing undersea kingdoms
drawing on his enhanced powers
aquaman summons an army of sharks whales
and sea monsters that utterly overwhelms
his opponents
it might sound like a silly power on
paper but aquaman
showed for the first time on screen that
arthur curry's powers
really are no joke at the heart of
shazam is
every kid's wish to become an
all-powerful superhero
the first half of the film takes a
comedic approach to this premise as
fourteen-year-old billy batson gains the
ability to transform into a fully adult
superhero
hey to fighting bad guys
you that is an actual vomit however the
film's best scene comes at the climax
when billy stumbles onto a unique
solution to stop the evil dr savannah
and his seven deadly sins
sharing his power with his foster
siblings as the kids
all shout shazam a bolt of lightning
transforms them into fully grown
superheroes
ready to take on savannah's army while
comic book fans might already be
familiar with the shazam family
this scene will doubtless surprise and
delight all kinds of fans in equal
measure
joker is a movie that managed to do what
no other
dc film does turn the clown prince of
crime into a genuinely sympathetic
character
the constant abuse levied against failed
comedian arthur fleck comes to a head
when he's invited onto a late night talk
show hosted by murray franklin the man
he once idolized
having previously been pushed to the
edge by murray's ridicule arthur
now fully inhabiting the joker persona
decides to take his revenge
originally planning to shoot himself on
live television arthur changes his mind
at the last second
and shoots murray in the face instead no
longer an insecure sad sack
this is a joker who has fully embraced
his demons showing how the most
human super villains could be the very
worst of all
margot robbie reprised her role as the
joker's ex-girlfriend harley quinn in
birds of prey and the result is an
off-the-wall film filled with delirious
fun the full title of the movie speaks
to the film's broader aims while
it's best scene perfectly communicates
them it's all about helping harley and
the birds find themselves
after being dumped by the joker harley
decides to reinvent herself by blowing
up ace chemicals
the factory where the joker transformed
her into his chalk white's counterpart
although harley makes this decision when
she's drunk and feeling impulsive
it's still a fantastic moment of rebirth
that decisively separates harley from
the joker's influence
as the factory goes up in an explosion
of flaming green smoke
and charlotte lawrence's the jokes on
you plays in the background
all of gotham city learns that harley
quinn is finally her own woman
wonder woman 1984 shows off a more
vulnerable side to diana
one who accidentally wishes for her dead
lover steve trevor to return to her
her wish comes true but as a consequence
diana's power begins to fade
this becomes a problem when she and
steve travel to egypt where the film's
antagonist
maxwell lord has taken control of an oil
tycoon's personal army
as wonder woman takes on the entire
convoy she discovers to reduce
strength speed and stamina make the
battle much harder
it's a very different side to wonder
woman especially compared to the one we
saw storming no man's land in the first
movie
despite it all she refuses to back down
and that's what makes the scene
so memorable one thing that most people
agree on about
zack snyder's vision of the dc eu is
that it's all
pretty dark this is made abundantly
clear in zack snyder's justice league
and arguably the film's most iconic
scene is the most despondent of all
for its epilogue the movie returns to
the apocalyptic
nightmare future first seen in batman vs
superman
in which superman has turned to evil and
earth has been overrun with darkseid's
parademons
most surprising of all batman has
entered into an alliance with his arch
enemy the joker
the partnership is purely one of
convenience of course and the joker
still takes sick joy in tormenting the
dark knight with his failures
but i'm happy to discuss with you anyway
like why you sent to boywonder
to do a man's job naturally batman
promises to one day make his arch enemy
really pay for his crimes but this is
the dynamic rarely depicted in dc's
live-action movies and it'd no doubt be
fascinating to see it further explored
in the future
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you